it started with a few hundred people in
different parts of sudan's capital
khartoum but soon the numbers swelled to
thousands protesters returning back to
the streets to voice their condemnation
of a deal signed between the army leader
general abdel fattah al-burhan and prime
minister abdullah last month the
agreement came after burhan led a
military takeover in october placing
hamdug under house arrest for nearly a
month
the deal has a lot of things that are
vague and can be interpreted in favour
of our demands or against it but the
problem is it was signed by someone who
doesn't have a right to sign it and
someone who doesn't deserve it
hamduck does not represent those on the
street and the military cannot be
trusted
the takeover saw the dissolution of the
two-year transitional government which
was shared by the military and the
civilian coalition known as the forces
of freedom and change they represented
the protest movement that led to the
overthrow of sudan's long-time president
umar al-bashir other regions around the
country also came out in protest of the
deal including the state of kasala in
the east darfur in the west and jizeera
state which neighbors hartung
asked the army can't be part of our
government because they are the ones who
come and kill us they can't be the same
ones to come and rule us so we're coming
out against the army chief burhan and
his deputy
they should not use their bullets and
tear gas on ice and our children let
them use it in war the army should be in
the barracks if they were wearing
civilian clothing they could have stood
with us
across the nile thousands gathered in
front of the presidential palace on
monday to voice their anger at the
military and the deal security forces
used tear gas to disperse them
since the takeover medical workers say
at least 44 people have been killed and
nearly 300 injured yet more protests are
scheduled for the coming days many here
say they won't stop until their demands
for a full civilian government is met to
guarantee sudan's transition to
democracy heber morgan al-jazeera
khartoum